(Audience cheering)
- Oh, thank you.
- That's so cute.
Is your hair new too?
- It is.
- Is that new?
I haven't seen it like that.
I love it.
- Oh it's short.
- Your whole vibe. I'm into. Yours too.
- Oh thank you. - It's good. No no.
Keep it on her. She looks great.
(Laughing)
- Last time you were here,
you were cooking a lot.
Do you still cook?
- All the time. Yeah.
- You love it?
- I do. - I need to get into it.
- I've been very lazy recently though.
- Oh really?
- Just from being tired or something.
- Yeah.
Well, you're working. -
But yes, I love cooking.
- But that's, that's why
tin fish is so convenient.
- What's tin fish?
- Anchovies are tin fish.
- Jesus. Is that what we ate last time?
I was like, look, that is love.
That shows how much I love you.
I was like, I'm gonna put
this hairy beast in my mouth.
(Groaning)
It was so gross, but I
actually, no, it wasn't.
I actually, it was pretty good.
- Yeah.
- Cause, but I had to imagine
it wasn't a hairy fish.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- But it was good.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- I should eat some now.
They have such small bones.
- They do.
They have these little,
it looks like hair.
They have these little wisps in them.
They're little bones.
- Ah
- Okay.
- Yeah. You feel like, like you're
on like naked and afraid or something.
You're like, there's nothing
else to eat or something
but it was actually pretty good.
- Yeah.
- How you did it. I will say that.
Did you bring any food today?
Cause I was just wondering.
- I did.
I thought, I thought that we
- Is it hairy?
- No, but it, it continues
the tin fish theme.
- Okay.
- I like fish
- But it starts from my root of it.
- Okay.
- My mother's salmon ball.
She didn't make it.
- A salmon ball?
- Yes. And it's a very sixties,
seventies like retro snack.
- Okay.
- Bring it out.
- Thank you.
- Okay. We're gonna try. Oh.
(Audience clapping)
Wait. This is the, okay.
- Thank you.
So it's like, it's basically
just like canned salmon
and cream cheese and some other things
- I was gonna say.
So I haven't had the
salmon version of this
but the like Southern poor version of this
it's just like a cheese ball.
- Sure.
- Like in the, yeah
- This one has-
- You have fancy salmon.
- Just tin salmon
- But just it's fancy. I think.
So. Wait, I'm gonna try it.
- Is it like a mousse?
Or do you to sort of savage with a knife?
- I spread it.
- Alright
- I think it looks like
there's some parsley.
- Okay.
- And I like salmon. That's good.
- You know, my, this is
like my mom's specialty.
And so I figured I could
talk about, you know
where my love of tin fish.
- Oddly tastes like tuna.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Yeah. - Definitely
salmon, it looks great.
- Mm
- It's so good.
And I also just saw that
ring on your finger.
Hey yeah.
That's a nice ring.
I like that.
You know what I'm gonna say?
I can't believe I'm gonna say it.
I like that.
But I liked your gross hairy
fish better the last time.
That was really
I'm just saying you won me
over on the anchovy thing
- Next time I'll do sardines.
- I will try anything.
Are y'all those people?
Will you try anything? - Yeah for sure.
- Yeah. Absolutely.
- All right.
So how much, see, everybody's so excited.
My band's excited, we're all excited.
So how much will Marvel let you say?
What can you tell us?
- I, they, they, I, I try not
to say basically anything.
- So you don't give trouble.
- At all.
And, and then just say, oh
it's a continuation of
both of our characters.
- Yeah.
- Which could mean anything.
- Ben's really good at
taking these kinds of
I feel like you're very good.
- You're good at navigating it?
- God. Now the heat's on.
- Make people excited.
- It's the weirdest thing.
You are out very, very
publicly talking about a film.
You can't talk about
that's an odd job to do
- That's hard. Yeah
- But you know, it's, it's
all part of acting, I guess.
- You've gotta be good at teasing
to get people excited about it.
- Little
- Yeah.
- And saying something
without saying much at all.
- I know.
- Like?
- This is an epic film.
Fans of Sam Raimi are gonna love it.
There is shock horror, jump horror
and some revelations
that'll blow your socks off.
- I love new character - It deserves to
be seen in the theater.
There's a great new character in it
as well as wonderful returning characters
and new character in this part of the MCU
as in, we haven't teamed
up before Scarlet,
which so there's a lot to enjoy.
- I wish I just kept him with me
every time I did an
interview. (Audience clapping)
- That's, you know what's interesting is
I've never really thought about that
when it comes to like
these kind of these kinds
of movies, like you can't,
you don't wanna reveal it.
You don't wanna be a spoiler alert,
but it's like you're here to promote it.
That's really hard.
- Yeah.
- We're like, how entertaining
are we talking about nothing.
- You're gonna enjoy everything
that I can't tell you right now.
So are you surprised sometimes when
you watch the Marvel
movies, like you're in?
Cause y'all don't get to
see everything, right?
- Yes. No.
I, I, I think especially cause
I come from Avengers land,
that becomes even more
secretive and they, if you wanna
if you wanna read it, you
have to read it on an iPad or
at least for me, I had
to, I don't know what
your privilege was.
And, and then it started to be
that I only got my own pages.
And so I have no idea what. I mean
- Is that hard?
- When we filmed infinity war,
we showed up to set at
the end of the movie
and they said, okay, so
the script pages are wrong,
you guys are all gonna turn to dust.
Sorry for people who haven't seen it.
But it was a very long time ago.
So I'm just gonna say it.
- It's your fault at this point.
Like whatever.
So you got there thinking you were
and then you found out you
were gonna go to into dust.
- Yes. They told us this like on the day
and we all were just
ready to shoot that day
and we're like, okay, well I guess.
- And you're like, I guess I just die.
- Yeah. I guess we're
just gonna disintegrate.
- I, I was so shocked at that.
I I'm so excited.
I love how I love how these
movies unfold especially anyway.
So why do you think Dr.
Strange is so moody?
This is my thing because, because here's
cause here's my thing.
This is why I'm asking because
like I get your origin story.
Like I get why you were
kind of a jerk, but anyway
but like the doctor
situation, but I'm like
why are you so moody?
You're like the most powerful,
like why are you so moody?
Is it because you don't have
a love interest because I
- It might be something to do with that.
You, you know, every one of these films is
like therapy for these characters and-
- Okay.
- Often therapy with themselves.
Hint, hint.
And I think you just have
to watch this one to see
but he learns a lot during this film.
- Okay. Cause I'm just, I don't even know.
I haven't seen it, but I'm just
like throwing it out there
to writers in the world.
Like I would love for you to
have a love interest again.
Anyway. So, (laughing)
I'm like, I just noticed someone
might be back in this film
and I'm like, come on, but
I dunno what's happening
but how do you, how do you
think he'd do in therapy?
Dr. Strange?
- He'd be, I think pretty uh-
- Would he just do this and disappear?
- Snarky. Yeah.
- Probably. Yeah. He'd just skip it.
- If he had to, I think
he would be pretty snarky
and defensive. I think it
would be quite a long slug.
But he'll get to it. He'll get to it.
He's not above learning.
I think we've reached a stage now with him
as a character where he's so
Omni missing an Omni present
and Omni everything that he
needs a, he needs a check.
He needs a check in for sure.
So this is very much
what the film's about.
It's sort of his evolution is
very much part of the story.
- I love it. I'm so excited.
I'm gonna keep saying it.
So your characters use
a lot of hand motions.
Like I just did like.
- Yeah, good.
- Okay. So I no you're welcome.
You're welcome.
So what I mean, do you have to
nail something specifically?
Or is this just your hand motion you made
up?
Cause you both of you.
- Um no.
- We both work with
different choreographers
- For this, you have to do it precisely.
- Yeah.
- What is yours again?
- Well, it, it depends what I'm doing
- It's always about like
moving some sort of energy
of some kind. So there's
always like a central
- Were you ever in dance?
Because I feel like - Yes
- Okay. Cause I was.
- That's my teacher appreciation
is my ballet teacher.
- Oh, that's so funny.
- Cause I was, I watch you
in the films and I'm like
this girl had to have been
a dancer or something.
Cause how you do your hands
and in your arms it's so like fluid.
It's nice.
- Yeah.
I work with someone who
is a professional dancer
as my choreographer and she's fabulous.
And start, I mean from eight years ago
starting from the first
film I did she's she's been
with me since then.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- And yours is you have
to make the precise circle
or what's happening. Like
- Mine's far more loose.
Like I just got like
that and stuff happens.
No, it's a similar thing.
We manifest energy through our
bodies that then gets kind of
extrapolated out into the
environment or at characters
that aren't there
and all the kind of magic that happens in
post-production. So
- See, I think that's harder as an actor.
Is that harder?
- You get teased a lot more
- Because I see you in
all these kinds of films,
I love both of you in
so many different films,
but in these kind of action
ones, is that harder to like
have to, pretend, that is
such an imagination hat.
- Sit in front of a crew.
- Exactly.
- But then you realize they're kind of,
it's the day job for them.
So that's all right.
You get over your embarrassment.
- The ridiculousness of it, like
- Yeah. And the end result is pretty cool.
- It's amazing.
That's what I'm saying - You
just have to go with that
- And it's like being a kid in a bedroom
and just imagining what's
not there, it's play.
Exactly.
- It really feels like play time.
- Yeah.
- I know.
But it's like, I feel like
that's harder to be like serious
and have, have this depth of characters
and all this stuff when you're having to
like basically pretend
you're a child doing a magic
trick. Like it's like.
- It is fun, in many ways it really is.
- Well, especially if something like
accidentally happens during it,
that makes you look super not cool.
Like there would be debris
that would just smack your face
while you're like, you know
trying to be so serious
or just getting slapped
in the face with accidental
leaves or something.
- It happens.
- Lizzie had her own sort of leaf blower
everywhere she went, there's this
her hair's kind of flowing the whole film
which basically meant
she literally had a fan
on her face for the, like a huge
- You're the Beyonce of the film.
- I am
- You are
- It does not matter where I am.
If I'm on the ground, if I'm underground
- Where's my fan?
- They're like where's Lizzie's wind?
And I, it was
- That's hard on me.
That's hard on me. It makes my eyes water.
- Yes. And then you're like,
I'm not supposed to be crying right now.
That's not the point of this scene.
- And my mascara, everything looks bad.
Okay. I'm gonna keep talking,
but we have to do a commercial.